let me sort of throw a curveball a
curveball at you then
uh what about recognizing the positive
and the negative of a fella with nice
facial hair called karl marx
sure
sure i mean i i i have a section in the
war in the west as you know where i go
for karl marx with some glee
so he seems to have gotten uh
you know some popularity in in the west
recently um not just recently yeah i
mean he's had a resurgence recently yes
resurgence well that's because that's
because whenever whenever things are
seen to go wrong people reach for other
options
and when for instance it's very hard for
people to accumulate capital it's not
obvious they're going to become
capitalists
and so one thing that happens is people
say let's look at the marxism thing
again see if that's a viable goer
and my argument would simply be
point me to one place that's worked
well the argument from the
marxist or the marxian economists is
that
we've only really tried it once the
soviets tried it and then if there's a
few people that kind of tried the soviet
thing cuba tried it
well they they basically it's an
offshoot of this show oh they tried
soviet yes they've tried it tried it in
venezuela
yes yes yes so but let's just let's just
quickly say
how did all these experiments go
they did not well they failed in
fascinating ways they did but they
failed yes they could and
we should stress so grossly failed
so grossly failed that they threw
millions and millions of people
into completely thwarted lives that were
much shorter than they should have been
yeah so the the lesson to learn there
that you can learn several lessons one
is that anything that smells like
marxism is going to lead
to a lot of problems
now
another lesson could be well what is the
fundamental idea that marx had
he was criticizing capitalism
and the flaws of capitalism so is it
possible to do better than capitalism
and that's if you take that spirit you
start to wonder that might actually
become relevant in i don't know 20 30 50
years
when uh the qual the um
the machines start doing more and more
of the labor all those kinds of things
you start to ask questions if i finally
might get to marx's dream of what the
average day would look like yes
well there's going to be an awful lot of
literary criticism then
if you remember that
said that we would be doing in the
evenings the labor in the evening well
he didn't know twitter was a thing or
netflix so he would he would change
there things we could learn from marx
plausibly possibly i can't think of
anything myself off hand but um
to have a critique of capitalism isn't
by any means a bad thing in the society
i'd rather that it was a critique of
capitalism that showed how you improve
capitalism a critique of a free market
that showed how people could get better
better access to the free market how you
could ensure for instance that young
people get onto the property ladder
things like that those are constructive
things the people who say we must have
marxism i mean don't know what the hell
they're talking about
because that never leads to any of those
things haven't led in the past
it's never led in the past and at some
point you've got to just you've got to
try to work out how many try how many
attempts you make at this damn
philosophy before you realize that every
attempt always leads to the same thing i
mean we could pretend that fascism has
never been properly tried
and that it was unfortunate what
happened in nazi germany but you know
that wasn't real fascism and
in mussolini's fascism you know didn't
go all that well but it was you know a
bit better and maybe we could try a bit
more franco fascism
nobody would have any time for this crap
nor should they the people who try that
are reviled and quite rightly so why do
we tolerate it with the marxism thing
and
it's a great mystery to me the way that
people do tolerate it always always in
this stupid way of saying we haven't
done it yet and if you keep trying the
same recipe and every time it comes out
as [ __ ]
it's the recipe's [ __ ] well sort of i'm
trying to practice here by playing
devil's advocate practice the same idea
that you mentioned which is
when you say the word marxism should you
throw out everything or should you ask a
question is there good ideas here
and the same it's the good it's weighing
the good and the bad and being able to
do so calmly and thoughtfully sure um
you know do you know the famous george
orwell uh
comment on the style with an argument
with a stalinist
do you know
that's one of my favorite quotes
george orwell in the early 40s gets into
an argument with a um a stylist
he's obviously a marxist
and the um uh this is after the show
trials 37
uh this is this is
when it's very clear what
marxism in the russian form is
and this uh uh all well is in the
discussion with this this this marxist
and it goes on and on and eventually
eventually orwell says well you know
what about the show trials and he does
and what about what's happened in
ukraine and
and
and the famines and and much more and
the purges and the purges and the purges
and eventually the
stalinist says oh well what oil knows
he's going to say all along which is he
says you can't make an omelette without
breaking eggs
and orwell says
where's the omelette
oh yeah so it's a good that's a really
good because look at this by this stage
okay how many where's my damn omelette
how many
just messy big bloody eggy piles
have the marxists created by now in
country after country yeah always next
time they're going to produce the great
omelet
but they never have and they never will
because the whole thing is rotten from
the start
but let me just also say one thing about
because of course marx isn't as nice as
he sounds
and that's one of the things that i i
try to highlight in the book is if we're
going to do this reductive thing of
people in history and saying well they
had views that were of their time
and we must therefore condemn them for
them saying fine let's do the same thing
with marx and there were things i quote
in this book from marx's letters not
least letters to engels and
indeed in his published writings in pa
pieces he was writing for the american
press
uh in the
1850s uh
the way he has horrible views on slavery
and and um colonialism and much more
but the main thing is i mean the
horrible things he says about uh black
people and the constant use of the
n-word in fact when i was doing the
audio book for the war in the west i had
to decide
will i read out the quotes from marx or
not if i had read them out i'd have been
cancelled because people would have just
said
you've been using the n-word so much in
this passage and you know this is and i
slightly thought of doing it so that i
could say i was only quoting marks
to try to hit the point home in the end
of course i was sensible and decided not
to but marx's letters are disgusting on
these terms since i highlighted this in
this book and some of the media picked
it up
um
and um
and have popularized this thing i'm
trying to put into the system which is
if you're going to accuse church of
racism if you're going to choose accuse
jefferson of racism washington of racism
and so on what about marx the two things
that marxists have said since this came
out has been first of all why are you
saying this about marx he was a man of
his time
like everyone else
and the second thing they say is we
don't go to marx for his horrible
abhorrent views on race so talking about
mixed-race people with guerrillas and so
on
we don't go to him for that we go to him
for his economic theories i say okay
well we don't go to thomas jefferson for
his views on slaves
we don't go to churchill
for his
the precise language he used that points
in the 1910s about indians or his health
advice or his health advice
actually i do get him for that
but that explains so much but
let's have some standards on this and
that's why i'm that's why i'm very
suspicious of the fact that the people
don't do this with marx because i think
what they're trying to what some people
are trying to do and this isn't this may
sound conspiratorial but i really don't
think it is i think that some people are
deliberately trying to completely clear
the cultural landscape of our past in
order to say there's nothing good
nothing you can hold on to no one you
should revere you've got no heroes the
whole thing comes down who's left
standing oh we've also got this idea
from the 20th century still about
marxism
or the 19th and 20th centuries
and no
no
you
will not have the entire landscape
deracinated
and then the worst idea is tried again
so basically destroy all of history and
the lessons learned from history and
then start from scratch and then then
it's completely any idea can work and
then you could just take whatever well
and the thing is there are always some
people with pre-prepared ideas and i
mentioned this also with the
post-colonialists the post-colonialists
were really interesting
because when the european powers were
removing were moving from africa in the
far east
post-colonial movements had one obvious
move they could have done which was to
say
since the european powers have left we
will return to a pre-colonial life
which in some other places would have
been returning to slave markets and
slave ownership and slave selling and
much more but put that aside for a
second
they could have said we have an
indigenous culture which we will return
to
almost uniformly in the post-colonial
era you had figures like franz fanon you
had european intellectuals like sartre
who said
the western powers are retreating from
these countries and therefore we should
institute in these countries what but
western marxism
well it's not obvious to me that like
the bad ideas would be the ones that
emerge but it's more likely the bad
ideas would emerge in this kind of
context when you erase history
when you're raised when you raise
history and you leave some ideas
deliberately
uninterrogated
i mean
as i say
find me
one in a hundred american students
who've heard of
any of the communist despots of the 20th
century
i mean name recognition in there was a
poll done a few years ago in the in the
uk and like name recognition among
children
school children for stalin let alone mao
i mean mao who kills more people than
anyone 65 million chinese perhaps
how many students in america know what
mao was who he was
where he was nothing or the atrocities
committed where the atrocities were
committed don't worry about that because
it mean it means that we might have
learned one of the two lessons of the
20th century we think we've learned one
of the
the two lessons of the 20th century we
actually haven't learned that lesson
we've learned a little bit of it and
we've not learned the other one at all
because that's why we still have people
in american politics and elsewhere
actually talking about collectivization
and things
as if there's no problem with that and
as if it's perfectly obvious and they
could run it and they'd know exactly
where to stop what are the two lessons
of the 20th century fascism and
communism
oh
yeah
i mean i'm not exactly sure what the
exactly the lessons are
no it's not clear if the lessons were
very clear that we'd be better at it
well one is
your book broadly applied of madness of
crowds
that's one lesson well
how so
meaning like um
large crowds can display herd-like
behavior yes be very suspicious of crowd
yeah in general i mean you apply it in
different more to modern application
yeah in a sense but
it's
that that's rooted in history that
crowds can when when humans get together
they can do some uh quite radically
silly things elias connect he's very
good on that crowd some power
um
and eric hoffer who is a sort of
self-taught
amazing
um
not the ultra didactic writer
the true believer and so on he was
extremely good on that
but the reason i mentioned the two
things no i mean we should have realized
the two nightmares of the 20th century
fascism and communism
that we should we should know how they
came about and we're interested in
learning how one of them came about
fascism and we know some of the lessons
like
don't treat other people as less than
you because of their race
that's one lesson
but when we've
we've done some good at learning that
um but the second one not to do
communism again not to do socialism
i i think we're
way away from knowing because we don't
know how it happened
and the little temptations are still
there always look at people saying i'm
going to expropriate your property
if people do things they don't like say
well we can't wait to take your property
well there's a sense there's an
appealing sense
okay every ideology has an appealing
narrative behind it
that sells the ideology so for socialism
for communism is that there's a
it seems unfair that the working class
does all of this work
and gets only a fraction
of the output it just seems unfair
so you want to make they do get a
fraction of that but yes
yes and so
it seems to be more fair if we increase
that if the workers own
um all all of the value of their output
and
well the things that are more fair seems
to be
a good thing i'd say well yeah i mean
fairness is
i like fairness as i just
no i much prefer fairness because it's a
much easier thing to
try to work out it's quite amorphous
itself for the concept but everyone can
recognize it
so for
instance
um
should the boss of the company
earn
a million times that of the lowest paid
employee doesn't seem fair
should they earn
maybe five or ten times the
the salary of the lowest yeah possibly
that that could be fair
there are certain sort of multiples
which are within
the bounds of
you know reasonableness
i i think actually that's the
that's the much bigger problem in
capitalism at the moment as i see it is
is the is the
not untrue perception that a tiny number
of people get a lot of the accrue a lot
of the
benefits
and that
the
the the bit in the middle
has become increasingly squeezed and is
it danger always of falling all the way
down to the bottom i mean i think in the
snakes and ladders of american
capitalism for instance it's
it's a correct perception to say that
the snakes go down awfully far
if you tread on the snake
you can plummet an awfully long way in
america
and the deal in the game was that the
ladders took you high
and there's a perception and again it's
not entirely wrong
that the ladders system on the board is
kind of broken
so what you're saying is you're
a marxist i'm douglas i'm a marxist you
heard that here first in the uh in the
out of context blog post you're going to
write about this i guess i can practice
point the way to critique capitalism if
it's gone bad is to get better capital
yes free markets where they're not fair
should be made fair
never
decide that the answer is the thing that
has never produced any human flourishing
i.e marxism
you